>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT FACING
ALMOST CERTAIN DEFEAT FOR HIS
PARTY IN THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
FIVE MONTHS FROM NOW, SGROOID
HAS BECOME DESPERATE.
HE'S DECIDED TO LEVERAGE THE
MURDER OF 19 CHILDREN IN TEXAS
LAST WEEK FOR POLITICAL
ADVANCES.
HE JUST SPOKE AT SOME LENGTH
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE ABOUT THE
NEED TO DISARM THE POPULATION
>> THIS ISN'T ABOUT TAKING
ANYONE'S RIGHTS.
ABOUT'S ABOUT PROTECTING
CHILDREN.
ABOUT PROTECTING FAMILIES.
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING HOLE
COMMUNITIES.
>>>
>> TO GO TO SCHOOL, TO A GROCERY
STORE, TO A CHURCH WITHOUT BEING
SHOT AND KILLED.
WE NEED TO BAN ASSAULT WEAPONS
AND HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
AND IF WE CAN'T BAN ASSAULT
WEAPONS, THEN WE SHOULD RAISE
THE AGE TO PURCHASE THEM FROM
18-21.
STRENGTHEN BACKGROUND CHECKS
ENACT SAFE STORAGE LAW AND RED
FLAG LAWS, REPEAL THE IMMUNITY
THAT PROTECTS GUN MANUFACTURERS
FROM LIABILITY.
ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
DEEPENING THE TRAUMA OF GUN
VIOLENCE AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT VIOLENCE.
THESE ARE RATIONAL COMMON SENSE
MEASURES AND IF CONGRESS FAILS,
I BELIEVE THIS TIME A MAJORITY
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WON'T
GIVE UP EITHER.
I BELIEVE THE MAJORITY OF YOU
WILL ACT.
>> Tucker: SO TO SUMMARIZE THE
PRESIDENT'S REMARKS TONIGHT,
YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS ARE
NOT ABSOLUTE BUT IN TAKING THEM
AWAY, WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY TAKING
AWAY YOUR RIGHTS WE'RE
PROTECTING CHILDREN TO WHICH YOU
MIGHT ASK, AM I A THREAT TO
CHILDREN?
THAT QUESTION IS NEVER ANSWERED
BY THE PRESIDENT.
THE POINT OF THIS, OF COURSE, IS
TO DISARM PEOPLE WHO DID NOT
VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN, AND THAT IS
WHY SIMULTANEOUS WITH THIS, THIS
EFFORT TO RECATEGORIZE THE GUNS
IN YOUR CLOSET AS FELONIES,
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN FAILING TO
FROM GUN CRIMES IN OUR CITIES
WHERE MOST OF THE CRIME IS.
AND IF YOU'RE AT ALL CONFUSED
ABOUT WHETHER THE EFFORT HERE IS
SELECTIVE, THAT THIS IS
ENFORCEMENT ONLY OF CERTAIN
PEOPLE, YOU'LL NOTICE THE
PRESIDENT NEVER MENTIONED THE
APPARENT FEDERAL GUN FELONY HIS
OWN SON COMMITTED WHEN HE LIED
ON A FEDERAL BACKGROUND FORM
WHEN HE BOUGHT A HANDGUN.
DIDN'T MENTION THAT.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
COMPLETELY IGNORED IT.
INSTEAD, BIDEN'S FELLOW
DEMOCRATS AND THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES SPENT THE DAY
DEBATING WAYS TO DISARM YOU,
AMERICANS WHO HAVE COMMIT IN
ORDER CRIME AT ALL AND WANT ONLY
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AND
FAMILIES.
DEMOCRATS PLAN TO CRIMINALIZE
WHAT THEY'RE CALL LARGE CAPACITY
HEEDING DEVICES, THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY ANY MAGAZINE THAT
CAN HOLD MORE THAN TEN ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION.
AS IT TURNS OUT, THAT IS MOST
MAGAZINES IN THE UNITED STATES.
10s OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
RIGHT NOW HAVE SO-CALLED HIGH
CAPACITY MAGAZINES IN THEIR
HOME.
THEY'RE NOT MILITIA MEMBERS OR
GUN NUTS THEY'RE NORMAL PEOPLE.
AND THE REASON THEY HAVE THEM IS
BECAUSE MOST MODERN HANDGUNS AND
RIFLES USE THAT TYPE OF
MAGAZINE, THE KIND THAT JOE
BIDEN IS TELLING YOU IS
THREATENING ESOTERIC.
THESE SAME FIREARMS, THE ONES IN
YOUR HOUSE RIGHT NOW WILL NOT
ACCEPT THE KIND OF DIMINISHED
MAGAZINES JOE BIDEN IS DEMANDING
YOU USE.
THAT MEANS IN EFFECT ALL OF
THOSE GUNS WILL BE BANNED.
WHICH GUNS SPECIFICALLY?
WELL, OF COURSE, THE GLOCK 19
PROBABLY THE MOST POPULAR.
IT COMES FROM THE MANUFACTURER
WITH A 15-ROUND MAGAZINE T GLOCK
19 IS NOT AN ESPECIALLY SCARY
FIREARM, IT'S A WORKMANLIKE
PISTOL.
IF YOU HAVE ANY INTEREST IN GUNS
AT ALL YOU PROBABLY ALREADY OWN
ONE.
BUT UNDER THIS BILL THE GLOCK 19
WOULD BE BANNED.
ILLEGAL.
A FELONY SITTING IN YOUR BEDSIDE
TABLE AND SO WOULD MANY OTHER
POPULAR FIREARMS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THIS IS ABOUT SAVING THE
CHILDREN, JOE BIDEN JUST TOLD US
BUT HOW MANY LIVES WOULD THIS
NEW LAW SAVE?
WELL, WE KNOW THE ANSWER.
ZERO.
NOT ONE.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE THERE'S
PRECISELY NO EVIDENCE AT ALL AND
NEVER HAS BEEN THAT LARGER
MAGAZINES SOMEHOW INSPIRE MASS
SHOOTING.
BUT OF COURSE SAVING LIVES IS
NOT THE POINT OF THIS.
DISARMING YOU IS THE POINT.
FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN JEB STUBY
TRIED TO EXPLAINED THAT AT A
HEARING OF THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
HOW DID THAT UNFOLD?
>> HERE'S A GUN I CARRY EVERY
DAY TO PROTECT MY WIFE, MY
FAMILY, MY HOME.
COMES WITH A 15 ROUND MAGAZINE.
HERE'S A SEVEN ROUND MAGAZINE
WHICH IS LESS WHICH WOULD BE
LAWFUL IF THIS WERE TO BECOME
LAW.
IT DOESN'T FIT SO THIS GUN WOULD
BE BANNED.
>> I HOPE THAT GUN IS NOT
LOADED.
>> I'M AT MY HOUSE, I CAN DO
WHATEVER I WANT WITH MY GUN.
>> Tucker: SO YOU HEARD A VOICE
IN THE BACKGROUND.
GREG OBVIOUSLY KNOWS HIS WAY
AROUND FIREARMS, THAT WAS HIS
GUN.
BUT OFF-CAMERA YOU HEARD SHEILA
JACKSON LEE OF TEXAS INTERRUPTH
GREG STUBY TO TELL HIM HOW TO
HANDLE A FIREARM IN HIS OWN
HOME.
IS SHE A GUN INSTRUCTOR?
WHAT DOES SHE KNOW ABOUT
FIREARMS.
SHE ONCE EXPLAINED TO US THAT
AR-15S SHOOT 50 CALIBER ROUNDS
AND WEIGH MORE THAN, QUOTE, TEN
BOXES, WHATEVER THAT MEANS.
SO SHEILA JACKSON LEE KNOWS
LITERALLY NOTHING ABOUT BY ARMS
AND YET SHE PLANS, WITHOUT SHAM,
TO REGULATE THEM.
BUT ONLY REGULATE YOUR GUN.
SHEILA JACKSON LEE HAS NO
INTENTION OF DISARMING HER OWN
BODY GUARDS FOR EXAMPLE, OR OWN
CONSTITUENTS.
THE DEMOCRATS BILL CONTAINS AN
EXPLICIT EXEMPTION FOR BODY
GUARDS EVEN SHE UNDERSTANDS THEY
MAY NEED MORE THAN TEN ROUNDS.
AND WASHINGTON POST AMERICAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
UBIQUITOUSLY CARRY HANDGUNS WITH
MORE THAN TEN ROUNDS AND OFTEN
MORE THAN FOOERNGS OFTEN WHY
THEIR RIFLES CARRY 30 MAGAZINES
NOT TEN.
WHY WOULD SHEILA JACKSON LEE'S
BODY GUARDS NEED ALL OF THOSE
BULLETS?
WHY WOULD ANYBODY NEED ALL THOSE
BULLETS AS CHUCK SCHUMER OFTEN
ASKS RHETORICALLY AND THE ANSWER
IS BECAUSE IT'S A DANGEROUS
WORLD AND IF YOU'RE SERIOUS
ABOUT PROTECTING THE PEOPLE YOU
LOVE YOU WILL BE SERIOUS ABOUT
THE FIREARM YOU CARRY.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT NOW DEMOCRATS
ARE NOT SERIOUS ABOUT PROTECTING
YOU OR YOUR FAMILY AND THAT'S
WHY THEY DEFUNDED YOUR POLICE
AND CALLED YOU A RACIST FOR
COMPLAINING ABOUT IT AS YOUR
CITY CO-LATCHED.
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT DEEPLY,
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT ANYTHING AT
ALL IS PROTECTING THEMSELVES AND
THAT'S WHY THEIR BODY GUARDS
WILL CONTINUE TO GET ANY KIND OF
MAGAZINE THEY WANT.
AND WHAT THEY WANT ARE HIGH
CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
DEMOCRATS SPENT THE REST OF THE
DAY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BAN WHAT JOE BIDEN HAS CALLED
GHOST GUNS.
GHOST GUNS, THEY'RE SCARY.
SEVERAL STATES TURNS OUT ALREADY
TRIED TO BAN GHOST GUNS BUT
EVERY STATE HAS RUN INTO THE
SAME PROBLEM.
NO ONE CAN SAY WHAT A GHOST GUN
IS.
IT'S A MADE-UP TERM.
IT HAS NO MEANING.
AS A JUDGE IN NEVADA PUT IT LATE
LAST YEAR WHEN HE STRUCK DOWN A
BAN ON GHOST GUNS, NEVADA WOULD
FACE THE RISK OF DISCRUMB MARRY
ENFORCEMENT OF PROSECUTORS AS
THEY IN THEIR SOLE DISCRETION
WITHOUT GUIDANCE COULD LABEL
ALMOST ANYTHING AN UNFINISHED
FRAME OR RECEIVER IF IT IN ANY
WAY RESEMBLES A FIREARM FRAME OR
RECEIVER.
IN OTHER WORDS ANY GUN COULD BE
A GHOST GUN IF DEMOCRAT OPTTIVES
SAY IT IS.
THAT'S HOW THEY LIKE IT.
THEY SAY A GHOST GUN IS A
FIREARM INCLUDING PARTS THAT
DOES NOT HAVE A UNIQUE SERIAL
NUMBER ENGRATE BY A LICENSED
MANUFACTURER.
OKAY.
BUT THE QUESTION IS, WHICH PART
OF A FIREARM SHOULD REQUIRE
ENGRAVED SERIAL NUMBER?
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
ON THAT QUESTION HANGS WHETHER
OR NOT YOUR POSSESSION OF THIS
OBJECT IS A FELONY OR LEGAL.
NOW, ACCORDING TO THE BILL, ANY,
QUOTE, ESSENTIAL COMPONENTS OF
THE FIREARM WOULD REQUIRE AN
ENGRAVED SEARIAL NUMBER BUT
HERE'S THE POINT, MERIT GARLAND
GETS TO MAKE THE CALL.
THIS BILL GRANDS MERRICK GARLAND
WHO IS A CRAVEN AND RUTHLESS
PART SANE WE KNOW THAT FOR A
FACT GRANTS HIM THE SOLE
AUTHORITY TO DEFINE WHAT AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT IS.
AND IF MERIT GARLAND DECIDES YOU
HAVE AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT THAT
DOES NOT HAVE AN ENGRATE SERIAL
NUMBER, YOU'RE GOING TO JAIL.
SEE HOW THIS WORKS.
ONCE AGAIN THE POINT IS NOT TO
STOP SCHOOL SHOOTINGS, THERE'S
NEVER BEEN A SCHOOL SHOOTING
WITH A SO-CALLED GHOST GUN.
IF YOU WERE INTERESTED IN
STOPPING SCHOOL SHOOTINGS AND
ALL OF US SHOULD BE YOU WOULD
TAKE A LOOK AT WHY THEY HAPPEN
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WHAT DO THE PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
THEM HAVE IN COMMON.
BUT NO ONE ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE
IS DOING THAT.
SO THIS ISN'T AN ATTEMPT TO STOP
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
IT'S NOT AN ATTEMPT TO MAKE THIS
A SAFER COUNTRY.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE.
THE BEGINNING OF A PLAN TO
CONFISCATE AND CRIMINALIZE
FIREARMSS IN THE HANDS OF THE
LAW ABIDEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU DOUBT THAT NANCY PELOSI
HAS ALREADY ANNOUNCED SHE WILL
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION BANNING
ASSAULT WEAPONS NEXT WEEK.
ASSAULT WEAPONS, WHAT'S AN
ASSAULT WEAPONS, ANY GUN HER
BODY GUARDS HAVE THAT YOU SHOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED TO HAVE.
ALSO A RED FLAG LAW THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE GOVERNMENT TO SEIZE
FIREARMS FROM ANYBODY IT WANTS
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COMMITTED A
CRIME.
NOW, UNDER OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
YOU HAVE TO BE CONVICTED IN
ORDER TO BE PUNISHED BUT UNDER
RED FLAG LAWS IF SOMEONE DOESN'T
LIKE THE CUT OF YOUR JIB YOU
LOSE YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
NOW THAT'S BALDLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND YOU KNOW IT
IS BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
SUDDENLY TALKING ABOUT PACKING
THE SCORE IN ORDER TO MAKE IT
LAW.
WATCH.
>> YOU WILL NOT STOP US FROM
ADVANCING THE PROTECTING OUR
KIDS ACT TODAY.
YOU WILL NOT STOP US FROM
PASSING IT IN THE HOUSE NEXT
WEEK, AND YOU WILL NOT STOP US
THERE.
IF THE FILIBUSTER OBSTRUCTS US,
WE WILL ABOLISH IT.
IF THE SUPREME COURT OBJECTS, WE
WILL EXPAND IT.
AND WE WILL NOT REST UNTIL WE
HAVE TAKEN WEAPONS OF WAR OUT OF
CIRCULATION IN OUR COMMUNITY.
EACH AND EVERY DAY, WE WILL DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO END GUN
VIOLENCE, WHATEVER IT TAKES.
>> Tucker: UH-HUH.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
REALLY?
WHAT'S THE MURDER RATE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY, PAL, AND WHAT EXACTLY
HAVE YOU DONE TO MAKE IT BETTER?
NOTHING.
MR. JONES WANTS POWER THEY ALL
DO AND TO THAT END HE WANTS TO
END THE FILIBUSTER DESTROY THE
ENTIRE JUDICIARY TO, QUOTE, END
GUN VIOLENCE.
A MOVE LIKE THAT RAISES A LOT OF
QUESTIONS, FOR EXAMPLE, DOES
MONDARE JONES HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
HE'S TALKING ABOUT LIKE THE
DETAILS, BECAUSE YOU'RE A
LAWMAKER.
FOX'S HILLARY VAUGHN CAUGHT UP
WITH HIM WANTING TO KNOW WHAT
WEAPONS OF WAR HE WANTED TO BAN.
INTERESTING EXCHANGE WATCH THIS.
>> YOU MENTIONED YOU WANT
WEAPONS OF WAR OUT OF
CIRCULATION.
WHAT IS A WEAPON OF WAR TO YOU.
>> ASSAULT WEAPON.
ASSAULT WEAPON.
>> IS THAT LIKE SEMIAUTOMATIC
HANDGUNS AND RIVALS.
>> SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS WOULD
QUALIFY AS ASSAULT WEAPONS AND
THEY SHOULD BE BANNED.
>> THAT WOULD TAKE ALMOST EVERY
GUN OUT OF PEOPLE'S HANDS.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
HANDGUNS FOR EXAMPLE WOULD NOT
QUALIFY UNDER WHAT I JUST
DESCRIBED.
I'M SORRY.
I'VE GOT TO GO.
>> OKAY.
>> Tucker: SO, YES, MONDARE
JONES JUST EXPLAINED, YEAH, ALL
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS WHICH
HILLARY VAUGHN SAYS HANDGUNS,
YES, HANDGUNS.
YOU WANT TO TAKE PEOPLE'S HANDS
GUNS AWAY?
NO THAT WOULDN'T QUALIFY AS
ASSAULT WEAPONS EVEN THOUGH HE
JUST DEFINED IT AS ANY
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPON.
SO CLEARLY MONDARE JONES KNOWS
WHAT HILLARY VAUGHN WAS TRYING
TO TELL HIM THAT MOST FIREARMS
IN THIS COUNTRY INCLUDING MOST
HANDGUNS ARE QUOTE SEMIAUTOMATIC
WEAPONS.
WE DON'T HAVE 22 CALIBERS THAT
AREN'T CAUSING A TON OF SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
BUT WHEN SHE POINTS THIS OUT HE
RUNS AWAY.
AND PROBABLY NOT BACK TO HIS
DISTRICT TO LOWER THE MURDER
RATE.
HE JUST DIDN'T WANT TO GET INTO
DETAILS.
SO WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT.
TODAY A GUY ONLE TWITTER SPIKE
COHEN SUMMED IT UP NICELY.
THE US GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
ARMING UKRAINE BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALLIES.
THE US GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
SEEKING TO DISARM RUSSIA BECAUSE
THEY'RE OPPONENTS.
IN TOTALLY UNRELATED NEWS, THE
US GOVERNMENT SEEKS TO DISARM
YOU.
WELL, EXACTLY.
THAT'S THE FRAMING.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
ANYONE WHO TRIES TO DISARM YOU
BY DEFINITION CONSIDERS YOU AN
ENEMY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO TO YOUR
ENEMIES.
YOU DISARM THEM.
YOUR FRIENDS, YOUR ALLIES, YOUR
CHILDREN, PEOPLE YOU LOVE.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO PREVENT
THEM FROM DEFENDING YOURSELVES?
YOU NEVER WOULD.
YOU CERTAINLY WOULDN'T SCREAM AT
THEM FROM THE PODIUM ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE KILLING CHILDREN IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN FAMILY THAT'S WHAT YOU
DO TO YOUR ENEMY.
YET SOMEHOW A LOT OF REPUBLICA